Caption: uh it's my great pleasure to introduce
Caption: our next speaker Derek Bingham he's a
Caption: speaker veteran but it's his first time
Caption: actually speaking at DDD Perth so we're
Caption: very excited to have him up on the stage
Caption: today Derek is a developer with a
Caption: passion for building software of all
Caption: shapes and sizes on any conceivable
Caption: platform and he's here to talk about
Caption: five design patterns to build more
Caption: resilient applications
Caption: thank you hello
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: come in come in take a seat take a seat
Caption: um yes thank you Carol my name is Derek
Caption: I am a developer Advocate at AWS and
Caption: today I'm going to talk to you about
Caption: resiliency and building resilient
Caption: applications now a little side story
Caption: about resiliency
Caption: I have done every role it's possible to
Caption: do at DDD I have been a room coordinator
Caption: I have been on the committee I have been
Caption: a floor coordinator I have just ran
Caption: around helping these awesome folks who
Caption: organize this this uh conference and
Caption: today is the first time after seven
Caption: attempts I actually made it as a speaker
Caption: resiliency yes yes
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: so in today's talk you'll fall into one
Caption: of three camps you'll either be in Camp
Caption: one where you'll think oh that's an
Caption: interesting pattern never heard of that
Caption: before
Caption: or you'll call Fallen Camp 2 and you go
Caption: well I know that pattern I've uh I've
Caption: implemented before but maybe not in
Caption: in.net so that's interesting or you'll
Caption: fall into
Caption: um Camp 3 and you'll go like go like
Caption: this oh flip not another one
Caption: more in that later
Caption: so for those of you who do not know me
Caption: and my flicker is not working
Caption: get closer get closer get closer it's a
Caption: big stage
Caption: reset the clicker
Caption: let's get start
Caption: there we go nope there we go
Caption: Brazilian the resilient clicker this is
Caption: not
Caption: um so for those of you who don't know me
Caption: um I have been building software for 20
Caption: years uh I am that old yes
Caption: um majority in Cloud so the last seven
Caption: or eight years I've been building
Caption: software in a number of different clouds
Caption: um what we call Cloud native so some
Caption: people call Cloud native
Caption: um others close
Caption: um and for four nearly five of those
Caption: years I have been working at AWS and
Caption: last two is developer Advocate
Caption: um you may notice a slight accent I am
Caption: originally from Ireland hence the uh the
Caption: green shoes that I that I'm wearing
Caption: today but I am very much a Perth native
Caption: and have been living in this beautiful
Caption: city for 15 years and I probably worked
Caption: with quite a few of you in the audience
Caption: so I'm sorry
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: clicker is of yes okay so a lot of
Caption: people I usually start talks with
Caption: um a quote
Caption: and it's usually called by somebody else
Caption: so I thought ah first ever DDD talk
Caption: let's have a quote from me so a lot of
Caption: people ask me Derek what do you do what
Caption: does a developer Advocate and so this is
Caption: what I say a developer Advocate is I
Caption: show people what I used to do for a
Caption: living
Caption: for a living
Caption: think about it
Caption: um so that's my quote and so today I'm
Caption: going to show you patterns that I used
Caption: to implement
Caption: um for a living
Caption: and I have to say I'm gonna have to stay
Caption: I love I love walking the stage but my
Caption: clicker's not working
Caption: oh now it's okay
Caption: um thanks thanks Carol so I'm going to
Caption: start with another quote this is from a
Caption: from a from a person a lot more famous
Caption: than I am
Caption: um this is the CTO of uh Amazon Dr Verna
Caption: vogels so failures are given and
Caption: everything will eventually fail over
Caption: time so when people hear this they're
Caption: like what everything fails nonsense
Caption: everything always works in my my machine
Caption: um or or they say oh okay and that's
Caption: that's the acceptance that you need
Caption: failure is a thing when we build modern
Caption: software applications that are
Caption: distributed we build them on different
Caption: platforms we go across networks that may
Caption: um go across boundaries of regions
Caption: countries uh all sorts of latency
Caption: introduced and they may also work on
Caption: different Hardware so nothing's ever
Caption: going to work all the time that's
Caption: ridiculous so what we need to do is when
Caption: we're building software we need to take
Caption: this in mind we need to build our
Caption: applications to be more resilient
Caption: it's terrible
Caption: click
Caption: so today I'm going to say five patterns
Caption: timeouts
Caption: graceful degradations retries
Caption: exponential back-offs and circuit
Caption: breakers and you'll see it's a
Caption: progression as I build these out and
Caption: then we're going to dive into one
Caption: practice the practice of chaos
Caption: engineering and that will become clear
Caption: why we're diving into chaos engineering
Caption: when we get to it
Caption: foreign
Caption: so the first thing to do is meet the
Caption: traditional distributed application that
Caption: we're going
Caption: to build today
Caption: before I get into it anybody who doesn't
Caption: like bad jokes you may as well leave now
Caption: because there's a lot
Caption: um a lot so I'm sorry I apologize
Caption: but not really
Caption: so this is our distributed application
Caption: it is a random joke generator
Caption: and here's a joke what do computers eat
Caption: for a snack microchips of course
Caption: and if it has a uh so it has a punch
Caption: line and a punch line and if I hit tell
Caption: me another
Caption: it's going to get another joke two hard
Caption: things in computer science cash
Caption: invalidation naming things and off by
Caption: one errors okay
Caption: um and then if I hit the back end of
Caption: this um front end I've got a setup a
Caption: punchline and a source all in Jason and
Caption: and if I refresh it'll hit an API that
Caption: will give me a result and that's the
Caption: application so if we look at the code
Caption: itself I have a client app so The Client
Caption: app is a react app which is basically
Caption: just one app.js and inside app.js I have
Caption: a fetch job component an inside vet's
Caption: job I have got basically two functions I
Caption: have got a um a rendered joke data which
Caption: renders uh the beautiful UI that you saw
Caption: earlier and I also have a if it's that
Caption: populate your data now this fetches the
Caption: Json object from the the back end API or
Caption: from the controller
Caption: now what it does it renders a response
Caption: in Json and displays it for your viewing
Caption: pleasure
Caption: so that is the UI then into the back end
Caption: it's a.net controller so what I'm doing
Caption: here I'm implementing what is an ideal
Caption: client interface this is all in.net but
Caption: don't worry you should be able to
Caption: understand it and
Caption: um what I do I call I instantly an HTTP
Caption: client I grab
Caption: um an endpoint and I call out to it and
Caption: I serialize deserialize the GS object
Caption: and return it back to the the front end
Caption: as a joke so what I'm doing I'm calling
Caption: out to a third-party API from this from
Caption: this controller
Caption: the joke object itself that I'm
Caption: serializing deserializing is that setup
Caption: punchline and Source since got
Caption: accessories and mutators as you'd expect
Caption: and then so then that's what you get so
Caption: you get tell me another calls the third
Caption: party joke API third-party Duke API
Caption: returns and why are monkeys great at
Caption: sports because they're born champions
Caption: got a few drones
Caption: um so that that that's our application
Caption: not like any good thing we need a an
Caption: architecture so the architecture is like
Caption: this so we have a react web application
Caption: I'd love to move over the other edge of
Caption: the debt of the of the stage but I'm
Caption: frightened at my clicker won't work
Caption: um react web application calls the.net
Caption: microservice so the controller I showed
Caption: you that then proxies into a third-party
Caption: joke API
Caption: which returns a joke to the controller
Caption: uh and then back to the react web
Caption: application
Caption: but what happens if the third party joke
Caption: API that I do not control that is a
Caption: third party rock has load runs into
Caption: errors and failed
Caption: well what happens then is the react
Caption: client doesn't know who that is filled
Caption: the.net microserver still proxies the
Caption: request uh to the third party joke API
Caption: and it just Waits uh it'll wait for
Caption: because I'm using the.net HTTP client
Caption: the default weight is 100 seconds so
Caption: it'll wait for 100 seconds
Caption: and that will mean the react web
Caption: application will also be wearing for
Caption: result from the uhnet microservice
Caption: the client might come along and do a
Caption: request for a new joke because we all
Caption: need bad jokes
Caption: and it will proxy it through the
Caption: third-party Duke API which is still
Caption: broken and again we'll get into this
Caption: problem of waiting uh for the default
Caption: timeout of the client request
Caption: and what will happen after after time is
Caption: the microservice will be just full of
Caption: these waiting requests and it will um
Caption: start to feel and keep it'll keep
Caption: cascading the failures back to the react
Caption: web application which will just keep
Caption: waiting
Caption: um
Caption: until yeah nothing so this is all very
Caption: bad for our users and a very bad
Caption: um experience for them
Caption: so let's go about fixing that and seeing
Caption: how we can apply patterns to make it
Caption: more resilient
Caption: the first pattern I'm going to Define is
Caption: timeouts so at the minute we're using
Caption: default timeouts for everything which is
Caption: a hundred seconds let's go about making
Caption: the timeouts more determinate
Caption: so here we are back in in the code
Caption: so if we look at the HTTP client object
Caption: in.net we can actually add a property to
Caption: that directly now the property is called
Caption: timeout imagine it's really titled I
Caption: must say and it is from second so I'm
Caption: going to give it five so that's going to
Caption: override the default behavior of 100
Caption: seconds and at least make things more
Caption: determinant so what's going to happen if
Caption: I Implement that is my my application is
Caption: going to change its Behavior someone
Caption: so if I refresh the the client
Caption: and you get another awesome joke if you
Caption: hit tell me another it'll keep returning
Caption: it will keep returning jokes as the
Caption: third party API is still up
Caption: and so if I hit tell me another it'll
Caption: keep returning until uh we get a failure
Caption: in the third party joke API
Caption: which we probably will when this is
Caption: spinning for more than five seconds so
Caption: at the minute it's spinning so that
Caption: means something is wrong so if we then
Caption: go to the the back end controller and do
Caption: the refresh you'll see boom we've got a
Caption: an unhandled exception uh which is
Caption: actually if you look down a timeout
Caption: exception so what's happened is the five
Caption: seconds
Caption: um has actually expired and it's bubbled
Caption: up a timeout exception
Caption: uh of five seconds so that that is a
Caption: very rudimentary
Caption: um use of a timeout we're just making
Caption: the requests more determinate
Caption: but that's that's only the start
Caption: um next the next phase of the
Caption: refactoring of this application is by
Caption: using a resilience Library called poly
Caption: is anybody used poly and net
Caption: excellent it is an excellent Library
Caption: um if you are not a developer don't
Caption: worry um there are
Caption: equivalent.net sorry equivalent
Caption: resilience libraries for Java there's
Caption: one inside spring if you're using the
Caption: AWS sdks all of these patterns are
Caption: actually built into them and there's
Caption: also I've seen a resilience library for
Caption: typescript as well so poly is just the
Caption: one for.net
Caption: so let's start using poly and really
Caption: expand in our timeout
Caption: so let's get rid of that that was um
Caption: our
Caption: default.net HTTP client timeout the
Caption: first thing we need to do in poly is
Caption: Define a policy so what we do is Define
Caption: a policy that wraps our timeout so we
Caption: say policy timeout async
Caption: um and then we need to give it a value
Caption: which again we'll set is five seconds so
Caption: the policy object comes from the poly
Caption: Library just for uh so you know and then
Caption: once we have defined the policy we need
Caption: to then put it in an execute so we're
Caption: wrapping it an async Executor and then
Caption: we'll pull once we've defined the async
Caption: method with a
Caption: um a a timeout token a token we will
Caption: then wrap our entire call DHCP client uh
Caption: up push it in to our executed async
Caption: Anonymous inner function and Define
Caption: a cancellation token thank you so why
Caption: why Define the cancellation token so the
Caption: cancellation token is now giving us
Caption: greater granularity into the calls so
Caption: we've got two async calls in here we've
Caption: got a HTTP client git async and a
Caption: content.read async
Caption: so the cancellation token will actually
Caption: allow us to cancel whatever task is
Caption: running
Caption: so we then finish and make that a return
Caption: to width and then we have five it and
Caption: see what's going to happen now to our
Caption: application again back at the front end
Caption: uh we'll have a similar Behavior where
Caption: the UI will will keep refreshing uh for
Caption: more than five seconds
Caption: and now if we go into the the controller
Caption: uh and we hit refresh
Caption: we'll see different Behavior so what's
Caption: happening now the third party API has
Caption: again failed uh but we've got a cast a
Caption: task uh canceled exception because the
Caption: cancellation token is invoked and that
Caption: has meant that
Caption: um the task is filled has bubbled up
Caption: that exception
Caption: so as you can see we're on a bit of a
Caption: journey here
Caption: um so we've got our timeout we've then
Caption: wrapped it in poly we've got a greater
Caption: granularity into the call stack but
Caption: um we're still getting
Caption: um exceptions we're still bubbling up to
Caption: the to the um the controller what's the
Caption: next stage in refactoring this
Caption: well the next stage the next pattern is
Caption: called uh graceful degradation
Caption: so like the name suggests
Caption: it's gonna degrade gracefully I.E we're
Caption: not going to uh we're going to have that
Caption: client or our beautiful users who are
Caption: using our beautiful joke
Caption: um creation or joke rendering
Caption: application actually get a result when
Caption: things go wrong so that's the whole
Caption: concept around uh graceful degradation
Caption: the application gracefully degrades now
Caption: how do we Implement a graceful
Caption: degradation
Caption: so again we need to Define what's called
Caption: a fallback so a fallback is thing that
Caption: you can present to your users when all
Caption: thing all other things are filled
Caption: so in poly I create a policy that
Caption: returns a joke list uh an enumable.net's
Caption: list and then on any exception
Caption: um it will do something
Caption: so what we want our fallback to do is to
Caption: return a joke so I'm executing a
Caption: fallback async that returns a a list of
Caption: jokes but for this demonstration I'm
Caption: simply going to return one joke
Caption: and I'm going to do that inside another
Caption: async anonymous function that has a
Caption: cancellation token just like
Caption: um we had in our um initial request
Caption: so Define it as a new list
Caption: once I've defined it as a new list I
Caption: then need to Define my joke
Caption: so the joke object if you remember has
Caption: uh basically three Fields it has a
Caption: source
Caption: a setup first
Caption: it has a punch line the all-important
Caption: punchline
Caption: and it has a source
Caption: so once I've defined that Source I'm
Caption: going to give it a name of fallback so
Caption: you know that when this renders you'll
Caption: see Source equals fallback
Caption: um on the UI so we can see that our
Caption: fallback has been returned
Caption: now we're going to what's called
Caption: Implement what's called a policy wrapper
Caption: this is this is where we can actually
Caption: Chi and policies together
Caption: using poly so the general fallback
Caption: policy that I've defined I'm wrapping
Caption: the original policy in which is our
Caption: timeout if you remember
Caption: so now
Caption: I'm going to change
Caption: and execute the policy wrap
Caption: okay so what's going to happen now is
Caption: we're going to return this joke if a
Caption: five second
Caption: timer occurs I'm in a band called 102.3
Caption: megabits or megabytes sorry
Caption: we haven't had any gigs yet
Caption: thank you thank you
Caption: claps are good thank you
Caption: so um so that's our fallback now if we
Caption: go back into our our UI let's have a
Caption: look and see what happens
Caption: so let's refresh this for F5 to work in
Caption: the application come up
Caption: there we go
Caption: um so UI controller third-party API
Caption: so we've went straight to the fallback
Caption: you see Source equals fallback
Caption: um you can see that we've hit the
Caption: fallback right away if I go tell me
Caption: another
Caption: there we are the third party Juke API is
Caption: recovered uh I tell you UDP joke but you
Caption: might not get it
Caption: there's even networking jokes in here
Caption: come on
Caption: uh refresh again and you've got I'm in
Caption: the band called 1024 so a fallback again
Caption: has has been invoked then I refresh that
Caption: and why don't werewolves ever know the
Caption: time because they're not when wolves
Caption: third party joke API sorry they can't
Caption: read that that was that was bad
Caption: um so that is our fallback we are
Caption: invoking it when the timeout of five
Caption: seconds happens
Caption: and returns a joke you can return a list
Caption: or a random entry in that list if you
Caption: wanted to but for brevity I'm returning
Caption: one joke only uh with the source of
Caption: fallback
Caption: and that's how you um do gracefully
Caption: degrade uh our API
Caption: cool
Caption: so that's that's great you say
Caption: um the third party joke API fails
Caption: times out after five five seconds users
Caption: always get a joke that we can determine
Caption: um well not really because we need to to
Caption: give the third party joke API more time
Caption: to if it's under load to recover and we
Caption: need to be able to not just try once to
Caption: get that joke from our controller to the
Caption: third party API we need to try it a few
Caption: times and that's where what a retry with
Caption: a retry is
Caption: so let's push a retry pattern into into
Caption: our application
Caption: so again
Caption: um we're just going to refactor the
Caption: general fallback into a method uh called
Caption: General fallback because I'm very
Caption: imaginative and then once you
Caption: um then the next thing we're going to do
Caption: is Define that retry policy
Caption: so the retry policy is it's fairly
Caption: straightforward
Caption: again type policy
Caption: on the handle
Caption: of exception now you could be more
Caption: generic I'm very generic in this
Caption: exception again for brevity but uh you
Caption: can be quite Pacific if you want
Caption: um and then once an exception happens I
Caption: want to retry async a number of times so
Caption: this time I'm going to retry five times
Caption: I'm then going to build that retry
Caption: policy into my policy wrapper so the
Caption: first policy I want to do
Caption: is the retry policy so I want to do the
Caption: initial request if that hits the
Caption: exception I'm going to retry five times
Caption: if that hits the exception five times
Caption: um then I'll handle my fallback I'm
Caption: going to change the timeout to two
Caption: seconds because you know five times five
Caption: is a long time so 5 times 2 is a bit
Caption: quicker so F5 that
Caption: and let's see what happens to your
Caption: application
Caption: front end first
Caption: loading loading
Caption: so third party API there are two hard
Caption: things in computer science we've had
Caption: that before come on Duke API
Caption: tell me another refreshing
Caption: so we'll know that if it's go over two
Caption: seconds so our time would sit to two
Caption: seconds so if this is loading more than
Caption: two seconds we know we're retrying and
Caption: now it's retried five times hasn't
Caption: worked so we're back to our fallback
Caption: because we've always got our fallback
Caption: and then tell me another 10 types of
Caption: people in the world those who understand
Caption: binary and those don't
Caption: um and then refresh again on our back
Caption: end
Caption: let's see what's happening there from
Caption: our controller's perspective
Caption: so it's taking more than two seconds so
Caption: we're retrying
Caption: and then well actually a third-party
Caption: apis come back again inside the five
Caption: retry window so we're getting a real
Caption: joke if I retry that again
Caption: it's pretty happy at the minute why the
Caption: buildable buy against all these it is
Caption: lunch at noon he was a creature of
Caption: Hobbit
Caption: no no
Caption: come on very topical
Caption: um
Caption: and this third-party Duke API as always
Caption: is very happy
Caption: fresh again
Caption: here we go so we're retrying
Caption: can we hit five yes there we go so uh
Caption: we're back to our fallback because we've
Caption: retried five times two second increments
Caption: and it's fell back to our fallback
Caption: and we'll just go over the code so two
Caption: second timeout
Caption: if the exception occurs over our retry
Caption: count of five then we will hit our
Caption: fallback exception
Caption: three tries
Caption: so that's retries and retries are really
Caption: really really nice but what happens when
Caption: you just implement retries
Caption: so just say I had this controller uh
Caption: just implementing the retry pattern and
Caption: I had many of these controllers all
Caption: hitting my third-party API
Caption: two second intervals
Caption: well what I've just created is a
Caption: distributed denial of service
Caption: application that's hitting that
Caption: third-party API and probably putting
Caption: under more load then it can probably
Caption: handle because everybody in the world
Caption: wants bad jokes
Caption: so what we need to do is improve that
Caption: retry pattern and Implement an
Caption: exponential back off
Caption: and I think I've got some I've got a
Caption: slide about this as well
Caption: so what's the exponential Buck off it's
Caption: simply backing off between retries
Caption: so as always our react web application
Caption: goes through and proxies through our.net
Caption: microservice and then may uh if it's
Caption: we'll time out after two seconds
Caption: after that two seconds it will then
Caption: retry
Caption: but with an exponential back off instead
Caption: of retrying after two seconds again you
Caption: actually wait for four seconds for the
Caption: next retry
Caption: and then eight seconds because the
Caption: timeout the time between retries is
Caption: increasing exponentially hence the name
Caption: and then finally
Caption: we'll have wit for 16 seconds and
Caption: hopefully after 16 seconds our third
Caption: party joke API will recover and return a
Caption: result to our react web application
Caption: so let's Implement a exponential back
Caption: off
Caption: in our code
Caption: so the only it's a pretty simple thing
Caption: to do so what we need to do is add a
Caption: little bit of maths to our retry logic
Caption: so luckily in Pulley there's a wait and
Caption: retry async method that I'm going to use
Caption: I'm going to
Caption: um
Caption: give it a duration of three
Caption: and a retry attempt number
Caption: and I'm going to time span between
Caption: retail attempts is this is where we want
Caption: to exponentially increase
Caption: so I used math.pal
Caption: I put in two because we want to do the
Caption: Power of Two by by the number of retry
Caption: attempts that we we have so it's 2 4 8
Caption: 16.
Caption: um well I'll render as
Caption: that's uh that's me exponentially adding
Caption: that's been adding exponential back off
Caption: to the code
Caption: pretty simple so when I do F5 and run
Caption: the application
Caption: we'll then have again a different
Caption: Behavior because what we're doing now is
Caption: we're giving that third party API time
Caption: to actually get working again
Caption: so here's our um
Caption: what do you call developer for Finland
Caption: nerdick
Caption: that's a new one tell me another
Caption: so as of over two seconds I can tell now
Caption: that we're retrying so in this case we
Caption: wanted to go 2 4 yet 16. so if this
Caption: spins for 16 seconds which I could tell
Caption: you when you're standing up here is a
Caption: very long time
Caption: um then we're gonna we should get our
Caption: fallback
Caption: and there we go yes right thank you uh
Caption: I'm a band uh tell me another and there
Caption: we go what's what's happened is a
Caption: third-party API has come back and we're
Caption: now getting jokes again because we give
Caption: it time uh we haven't hit it every two
Caption: seconds we've actually um hit it two
Caption: four
Caption: yep 16. no I've chose two seconds
Caption: because it's arbitrary you can choose
Caption: the number uh that actually fits your
Caption: use case uh in your um what user
Caption: Behavior you want to see in your
Caption: application uh but for this little um
Caption: demonstration I've chose two seconds
Caption: because you really don't want to sit
Caption: there and watch that spinning wheel for
Caption: for a minute or whatever
Caption: but there's more
Caption: so that that's
Caption: exponential back off but exponential
Caption: back off is not enough because it's a
Caption: very popular pattern everybody if
Caption: they're implementing retries is also
Caption: doing exponential back off with three
Caption: tries now what happens is yes we have a
Caption: broader distrib distribute notation of
Caption: retries but what happens is everybody
Caption: does it uh exponentially and so our
Caption: retries actually end up clustering
Caption: anyway
Caption: so
Caption: the whole problem that we're trying to
Caption: fix I.E hitting that trying to give that
Caption: server or API third-party API chance to
Caption: recover or actually
Caption: um we're not doing it because we're
Caption: still hitting it all at once as you can
Caption: see in the left-hand diagram those
Caption: requests are all clustering
Caption: um as they come in
Caption: so what we want to do is actually
Caption: flattening flatten make those requests
Caption: actually random we don't want to get
Caption: spikes of requests all coming at once to
Caption: a third-party API because it's going to
Caption: crash again we need it to recover
Caption: so what we do is we add Jitter
Caption: now there's a link there in the slide so
Caption: we have
Caption: um what's called a builder's library
Caption: in Amazon AWS amazon.com gives you a
Caption: list of all these patterns and how to
Caption: implement them
Caption: um Jitter is just one of the patterns
Caption: there's a whole lot of different uh
Caption: patterns that you need when you're
Caption: building Cloud native applications
Caption: so let's see how we would Implement
Caption: exponential back off with Jitter in our
Caption: application
Caption: so what we need to do is Define a bit of
Caption: Randomness to this retry
Caption: and so luckily in.net there is a
Caption: math.random uh which we can Define
Caption: inside of time span so what I'm doing
Caption: here I Define a time span of
Caption: milliseconds and inside I'm going to
Caption: Define that as a new random number so
Caption: I'm adding a random amount of time
Caption: between each retry
Caption: so that if in effect flattens the the
Caption: retry curve
Caption: and that's it that's all you have to do
Caption: to implement Jitter in a retry so it's
Caption: you should you should do it basically
Caption: so that's um exponential Buck off with
Caption: Jitter
Caption: now we're going to get into
Caption: um the fun one circuit breaker
Caption: so what is a circuit breaker so if you
Caption: have a we have a react web application
Caption: proxying third-party Duke API it's
Caption: breaking randomly
Caption: and we keep retrying and we're using
Caption: exponential back off with Jitter
Caption: retrying retrying hopefully I'll come
Caption: back
Caption: but what if we wanted to reduce the load
Caption: completely off the third-party Duke API
Caption: for a period of time you know at the
Caption: minute we're just implementing retries
Caption: with Jitter and exponential back off but
Caption: ultimately it's hitting it's hitting
Caption: that third party dual kpr
Caption: well this is where a circuit breaker
Caption: comes in so a circuit breaker is
Caption: something that you can Implement that
Caption: will actually stop
Caption: um requests going through to the third
Caption: party API or other service that that you
Caption: choose for a number of minutes why would
Caption: you implement a circuit breaker because
Caption: it's giving ultimately this third-party
Caption: API no requests so it can spin up it can
Caption: fix itself and hopefully come back so
Caption: with the circuit breaker the request
Caption: when it comes back it comes back from
Caption: the circuit breaker itself and returns
Caption: to the react web application
Caption: so now any other subsequent request in
Caption: that time span of the circuit breaker
Caption: will be quick responsive and the um the
Caption: users will be happy they won't be
Caption: waiting for a time I retry or an
Caption: exponential retry or anything like that
Caption: they will get a more responsive um
Caption: response for their request
Caption: so let's Implement a circuit breaker
Caption: with a circuit breaker you need some
Caption: steers so you have to store State inside
Caption: um you where you're calling it or where
Caption: you're implementing it so I'm just going
Caption: to refactor this a little bit and
Caption: refractor what we've got into a global
Caption: field so policy wrap will become a
Caption: global inside the controller and then
Caption: I'm just going to pull what I've got
Caption: already and refactorize that into a
Caption: method because that's not going to
Caption: change what we need to do is add to it
Caption: so extract the method
Caption: and call it init policies
Caption: so there we go so what we've basically
Caption: got is the init policies called and then
Caption: we we call the the API with the right
Caption: policies
Caption: so inside the net policies itself let's
Caption: let's jump into it after I've tidied it
Caption: up
Caption: so nothing's changed we've got our retry
Caption: General fallback and and his initial
Caption: policy
Caption: now we need to Define
Caption: what is our circuit breaker
Caption: now a circuit breaker itself is is a
Caption: policy
Caption: you define it as a policy just like the
Caption: rest
Caption: now again I'm catching a very high level
Caption: generic exception
Caption: but in poly we have actually got a
Caption: circuit breaker async method
Caption: what we're doing we're saying circuit
Caption: breaker if um
Caption: you stay active for a time span after a
Caption: number of exceptions so what that's
Caption: defining is the circuit breaker itself
Caption: saying ah if I catch five SEC exceptions
Caption: and go Implement myself and stay active
Caption: for one minute
Caption: once I've defined the circuit breaker
Caption: policy I need to then Define what to
Caption: return from the circuit breaker for that
Caption: one minute when it's uh in operation
Caption: and this is another fallback so I'm
Caption: going to call this one a circuit breaker
Caption: fallback now I could have used my
Caption: existing fallback if I wanted to but I
Caption: need to handle this circuit broke
Caption: exception so this is why I'm
Caption: implementing a Pacific fallback for the
Caption: circuit breaker and also to demonstrate
Caption: when it's invoked
Caption: so on broken circuit exception I need to
Caption: return another fantastic joke
Caption: and that's what I'll do here so again
Caption: fallback async
Caption: which will have a an innumerable of type
Caption: joke again I'm only returning a single
Caption: joke for brevity
Caption: async Define cancellation token
Caption: and let's define the joke
Caption: so the joke this time I'm gonna have to
Caption: come up with uh something even better
Caption: than a band of 1023 megabytes so again
Caption: this is
Caption: um we've got our object so object that a
Caption: joke is so a setup punchline and source
Caption: but this time the source is going to be
Caption: a circuit breaker so we can tell that
Caption: the actual circuit breaker has been
Caption: invoked
Caption: cool
Caption: and then we add it to our policy wrapper
Caption: so we want to make sure that this is
Caption: called
Caption: after five exceptions so we need five
Caption: exceptions so we put it after the retry
Caption: we say invoke circuit breaker fullback
Caption: Wan
Caption: a circuit breaker policy happens
Caption: I.E by exceptions
Caption: cool and that's our initial policy at
Caption: the bottom
Caption: so what's going to happen is we're going
Caption: to set up
Caption: let's go so why did
Caption: why did the developer
Caption: go broke
Caption: because
Caption: they used up all
Caption: their Kish
Caption: cash
Caption: thank you
Caption: um so F5 that and let's see how our
Caption: application behaves
Caption: this is the the application you're
Caption: coming to know and love
Caption: um so
Caption: let's go to the UI first
Caption: so what we're doing we're
Caption: oh it's we've got into our um circuit
Caption: breaker right away so
Caption: um we'll refresh that
Caption: again so as our circuit breakers invoked
Caption: we we're always going to get our circuit
Caption: breaker fall back for the next minute so
Caption: we can refresh refresh you see how
Caption: responsive the application is getting
Caption: and it's always returning in the same
Caption: joke I.E or circuit breaker fallback
Caption: um which is great but if we wait a
Caption: minute we should we should then see the
Caption: state change and actually the um we'll
Caption: we'll call again our third party API
Caption: after the um the circuit breaker
Caption: has went away
Caption: um for the minute so that's that's um
Caption: that's circuit breaker
Caption: um sometimes
Caption: it's it's it's we implemented to just
Caption: improve the um responsiveness of our
Caption: application
Caption: so we're gonna give it a minute
Caption: still active refresh should be a minute
Caption: by night
Caption: how many programmers take to change the
Caption: light bulb it's a hardware problem none
Caption: uh third party API thank you very much
Caption: for that jam so it's back so a
Caption: third-party apis is back and now we'll
Caption: we'll be hitting it again
Caption: um and if we get have a number of
Caption: retries that that fall and hit R5 that
Caption: hit our circuit breaker the circuit
Caption: breaker will be invoked again
Caption: um but now our third party took apis
Caption: behaving for now uh but we've got that
Caption: circuit breaker fallback if if if if we
Caption: need it
Caption: cool so that's that's um
Caption: that's implementing the five practices
Caption: now
Caption: I want to end on the practice of chaos
Caption: engineering because what you've just
Caption: witnessed uh today is the practice of
Caption: chaos engineering you may not have known
Caption: it
Caption: so chaos engineering is the process of
Caption: stressing an application by creating
Caption: disruptive events observing how the
Caption: system responds and implementing
Caption: improvements so what have we done we've
Caption: stressed our application our application
Caption: is a third-party joke API we've been
Caption: requesting new jokes and sometimes we'll
Caption: be getting some absolute cracking jokes
Caption: I think you'll agree at other times
Caption: um you know it's it's broken
Caption: so we've been but when it breaks we've
Caption: been observing how our system responds
Caption: it has a little spinny wheel it throws
Caption: exceptions
Caption: um and with that in mind we've started
Caption: implementing improvements so we've
Caption: implemented retries exponential
Caption: back-offs with Jitter and then finally
Caption: circuit breakers
Caption: but think of chaos engineering as this
Caption: lovely Little Wheel
Caption: and where we start with steady state our
Caption: application is happy
Caption: we then come up with a hypothesis I can
Caption: nearly speak and we think well what will
Caption: happen to our application if we do X
Caption: so let's do that using the AWS fault
Caption: engine simulator this is what I've been
Caption: using to kill the third-party joke API
Caption: so what I do I create an experiment
Caption: and I create an experiment using an
Caption: experiment template where I go
Caption: description
Caption: stop instances
Caption: I then give it a role so it allows me to
Caption: stop those instances
Caption: I then give it an action so again I just
Caption: want to stop the instances please
Caption: a brief description
Caption: and then an action type so the action
Caption: type is you choose a service that you
Caption: want to invoke this action on and in
Caption: this case ec2
Caption: and then you give it a duration so I'm
Caption: stopping my ec2 instances that are
Caption: running the third-party Duke API for a
Caption: minute and that's my hypothesis that I'm
Caption: defining here
Caption: I Define what I'm going to Target by
Caption: using tags so all of the ec2 instances
Caption: that are running my third-party joke API
Caption: are all tagged with the value of API
Caption: so I I set that up here
Caption: and then I create my experiment it gives
Caption: you all these warnings because you
Caption: actually are going to stop real
Caption: instances and there they are they're
Caption: running at the minute they're happy
Caption: and I can then run my experiment
Caption: another warning because even though it's
Caption: called default injection simulator it
Caption: actually does stop the things
Caption: um so that's why there's All These
Caption: Warnings so what's happening now is my
Caption: experiment is starting to run
Caption: and currently if I keep refreshing
Caption: you'll see that although my apis are
Caption: starting to run I just give it some time
Caption: for this experiment to invoke
Caption: now it's running
Caption: I refresh my third party took apis and
Caption: they're all stopping and so now I my
Caption: application that's calling this
Caption: third-party joke API needs to deal with
Caption: these things stopping
Caption: and this is where we go to the next
Caption: phase in the in this cycle after we've
Caption: run our experiment we'll then verify so
Caption: verify verification is what we were
Caption: doing earlier we were running our
Caption: application and verifying what was
Caption: happening
Caption: then after a minute and We've ran our
Caption: application and uh our API is not
Caption: working we've built our resilient
Caption: applications and build our patterns
Caption: the apis actually come back because the
Caption: fault injection simulator experiment
Caption: defined a minute and so our apis are now
Caption: working as as they should
Caption: so that is
Caption: how we Define chaos engineering we have
Caption: verified what happens when the
Caption: third-party apis are down for a minute
Caption: and then we start improving them and we
Caption: improve and we improve them using the um
Caption: the patterns that I defined earlier
Caption: as well as stopping instances we can do
Caption: other things in ec2s ECS container
Caption: systems RDS database service so a lot of
Caption: different services in AWS support fault
Caption: injection
Caption: and this is what we've done today so
Caption: um
Caption: I'd like to thank our sponsors without
Caption: them we will be nothing uh if you want
Caption: to ask more questions because we're
Caption: running out of time about this in any
Caption: anything else about AWS I'll be at the
Caption: booth for the rest of the day
Caption: um looking fatigued but please don't let
Caption: that put you off please comment and come
Caption: and speak to me I was always good for a
Caption: chat
Caption: all the code today is on my GitHub repo
Caption: as well which is decob as well as my
Caption: Twitter handle thanks everybody for uh
Caption: listening and and helping me get through
Caption: all of these bad jokes thanks for the
Caption: clap over there a few groans over there
Caption: and then there's a few I already knew
Caption: all this stuff over there so that's
Caption: that's that is the three the three areas
Caption: that everybody fill into so thank you
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: foreign